die ader
ich werde noch fett durch diese ganzen
essens videos eine fanta mitgenommen ich
hätte auch in wasser nehmen können naja
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und willkommen bei
einem neuen video jahren hätte ich hoffe
natürlich gibt es gut heute mal etwas
ungewohnt war er sehr komischen
perspektiven die ist und ich wissen ich
bin gerade im skiurlaub und ich habe den
anfang von einem video leider nicht
aufgenommen deswegen müssen wir es jetzt
mal hier mit meiner neuen kleinen kamera
machen ich hoffe das ist okay das ganze
video hat mich so weit schon abgedreht
es geht heute nämlich um eine
schlechtesten dönerladen wollen dass
schon das habt ihr euch sehr sehr oft
gewünscht habe ich ganz oft gelesen und
die einzige partie noch fehlt ist zu
zeigen wie der bewertet ist was da so
drunter steht und nach dem laden zum
essen zur bedienung halt wie war ihr
kennt das dass solche einfügen euch
einmal seinen kleinen einblick geben ist
ja ganz ganz wichtig und dann geht es
auch schon los mit dem video der
dönerladen ist mit 2,4 stern bewertet
und war damit der einzige laden in köln
mit 2 kommend was also alles andere war
mindestens 3,5 oder so also der welt
heraus geschossen und hat halt auch mit
abstand am meisten einstellen
bewertungen und dann schauen wir mal
kurz rein ziemlich kleiner dünner für
fünf euro geschmacklich war es eher
unterdurchschnittlich für eine normale
cola ist mehr als übertrieben
nie wieder viel zu kleine portionen sehr
überteuert und schlecht im geschmack
noch nicht schlechter gegessen
die currywurst pommes im laden dem an
kosten zwei euro weniger die portionen
dort ist doppelt so groß in die wurst
fetter wurst
das ist eindeutig komplette abzocke fünf
euro für einen halben dollar ich bin
ziemlich enttäuscht und sauer einstellen
ist dafür dass man ihn essen kann und
für die lage ansonsten warte ich ab seid
vorsichtig zunächst einmal möchte ich
erwähnen dass dieser text ausschließlich
mit meinem mittelfinger getippt wurde
alles klar als ich mir dollar bestellt
aber war neben der preis ist ein bild
eines großen perfekten dinners ist
dementsprechend enttäuscht gerne zu
bieten als ein normales brötchen fleisch
und salat gefühlt ankam
ich hatte eigentlich schon dünner
bildschirm gut die bewertung ist acht
monate alt ich habe auch ein paar
vermutung wieder im video aufgestellt
wie das denn
hinkommen so also diese schlechte
bewertungen zwischen diesen ganzen
einstellen bewertungen gibt es
allerdings auch immer wieder zu drei
stellen dass zum beispiel ihre der döner
war ganz gut
ja aber die schlechten bewertung häufen
sich halt das ist mir aufgefallen
deswegen habe ich denn für euch mal
getestet und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß mit dem video passt mir sehr gerne
daumen nach oben dafür weitere platz
macht mir sehr viel spaß und schreibt
ihre weitere restaurants nicht hast so
in die kommentare
wie immer erst was ich im video glaube
ich gar nicht gesagt hat ich hatte
meinen döner auf fünf euro bezahlt der
war jetzt vielleicht nicht so riesig ich
würde aber eigentlich sagen normalgröße
und für die fand ich dazu heute noch
einmal zwei euro oben drauf also
insgesamt sieben europäischen
durchschnitt muss man ganz klar sagen
schaut selbst jetzt los
leute auf geht s mir statt ich muss
allerdings erst noch zu media markt weil
ich kaufe mir gleich noch einmal kamera
so eine kleine glocke normalerweise film
ich habe alles mit dieser hier das ist
eine sony dies allerdings ziemlich groß
und und keine ahnung für manche videos
passt das nicht so deswegen muss man
eine neue her sonne kleine nennt sich
canon powershot g 7 markt 2 kennt ihr
vielleicht benutzen sehr viele youtube
und die hole ich mir auch mal so leute
ich bin hinter statt jetzt war ich
gerade auch bei media markt hat mir hier
die kamera gekauft mir ist aufgefallen
der dönerladen hat nur bis 20 jahren
schon halb acht deswegen muss ich mich
jetzt ein bisschen beeilen was
eigentlich ganz gut ist da ist dann so
einen gorillapod auch direkt dabei
gewesen hätte 14 550 euro glaub ich
packe die man schnell aus weil ich
wollte dir eigentlich direktwahl festen
vielleicht es dann jetzt auch ein
bisschen dumm da kommt jeder tut sich
nicht viel blöd dann muss ich wieder mit
handyfilm wir gehen rein weil ich will
natürlich ich finde das immer so
unangenehm einfach stummfilm wahlen wenn
es dann jetzt auch um den schlechtesten
dönerladen geht jetzt werde ich dann
nachher rausgeschmissen deswegen würde
ich sagen wir es wird schon aufs handy
und holen uns mal entspannten boehner
ja das ist gleich also leute wir sind
mal wieder relativ zentral in der
innenstadt und jetzt kann ich vielleicht
mal war das dümmste wäre natürlich wenn
er plötzlich zu ist früher war ich hier
schon mal ein video drehen
genau an dieser ecke re vorne aber
interessiert ja wahrscheinlich kein
[Musik]
cable
in new york
[Musik]
weinreich
wir machen weiter so
schon lang
wir haben noch arbeit vor
so leute ja hier habe ich den döner die
fanta ich würde schon wieder draußen
eigentlich den eingepackt mitnehmen hat
jetzt leider nicht ganz so geklappt aber
gut ich habe ihn auch nicht die ganze
zeit so wirklich verstanden er war
irgendwie voll witzig so glaube ich aber
ich habe die hälfte nicht verstanden
da muss man immer so aufzwangen grinsen
kennt ihr das leute ich hab die ganze
zeit hin und her überlegt hätte ich den
döner ist doch irgendwie in der stadt
film ich das mit meinem handy weil er
ist ja sonst kalt mache ich es nicht wie
solche dann überhaupt mit nach hause
bekommen im auto jetzt habe ich mich
aber doch für das zweite entschieden
also wir haben jetzt mit nach hause
genommen
ich zeige euch erstmal wieder so
aussieht allerdings muss ich sagen der
riecht wirklich extrem lecker und für
mich hat der laden auch absolut gar
nicht den eindruck gemacht als wäre das
irgendwie schlechte qualität oder so
also ein ganz normaler typischer
dönerladen in einer großstadt das ding
ist ja auch in so einer lage kann man
sich das gar nicht erlauben irgendeinen
scheiß zu verkaufen weil wenn ich jetzt
extrem schlecht ist spricht sich das
natürlich schon rum und dann ist halt
der nächste der in den laden rein kommt
aber kann ja auch sein dass er letztens
erst der besitzer gewechselt wurde
keine ahnung und was ich wirklich sagen
muss der war echt richtig korrekt zu mir
hat so gesagt so ja ich mache dir
frisches fleisch auch bei vielen ist das
so die sagen ja machen wir frisch aber
nehmen dann so das was unten liegt also
hat er seinen kleinen witz gemacht glaub
ich hab ich zumindest so aufgefasst und
jetzt haben wir hier den döner
ich zeige ihnen euch gerne mal oder ich
will mal kurz rein so ich mag es immer
wenn das so gemischt ist also nicht dass
der salat oben drauf ist und was mir
endlich auch einmal sehr wichtig ist
dass ich weiß dass das vielleicht gute
qualität hat weil sonst habe ich immer
das gefühl kennen ja vielleicht einige
von euch
[Musik]
also vielleicht ist auf jeden fall viel
drin ist mit cocktails ist mein
lieblings hose und jetzt weiß ich
einfach mal rein
also ich muss sagen was die soße angeht
habe ich auf jeden fall schon besser
gegessen
trotzdem schmeckt wirklich frisch und es
schmeckt auf keinen fall schlecht ich
werde noch fett durch diese ganzen
essens videos eine fanta mitgenommen ich
hätte auch in wasser nehmen können na ja
und ich muss jetzt auch sagen ist nur
meine persönliche meinung wir haben halt
obendrauf heute viel fleisch und der
salat ist irgendwie unten drunter
aber das sind dann halt so kleinigkeiten
jetzt hab ich auch noch mein t shirt
folge sorgt also hier müsste ich sagen
die zwei sterne bewertung basiert mal
wieder auf deutschen touristen die
irgendwie immer was zu meckern haben
würde ich einfach mal so behaupten
um ehrlich zu sein oder die haben halt
einfach pech oder vorher war dann
anderer besitzer drin ich war aber zu
100 prozent im richtigen laden
schlechteren döner gab es nicht das war
der schlechteste aus köln zumindest von
den bewertungen her ich hoffe dass
wieder hat euch gefallen dass mir sehr
gerne daumen nach oben dafür weitere
parks schreibt ideen und wünsche in die
kommentare was ihr euch wünscht wo soll
ich hin was sind eure
lieblingsrestaurants was in eure us
restaurants was soll ich ausprobieren
ich bin gespannt
sollte mir sehr gerne auf instagram
abonniert den kanal hotline